salut aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour un
nouveau casse-tête un casse-tête à un
milliard d'euros
c'est faux c'est parce que je peux pas
en acheter toujours de plus en plus cher
donc là on fait un cast est très cool
fabriquer fabriquer kéké fabriquer
quelques gâteaux par konstantinou par
constantin j'appelle la ebox qui
apparemment assez difficile mais qui
alerte il est sympa original sa part
avec des couleurs c'est une boîte il va
falloir l'ouvrir en toute manière ne
l'aurait pas happer livebox il est pas
bête au bessat ses sorties quand j'ai
tourné
c'est intéressant on va passer un bus
est rentré à ces sorties titre donc bien
s'amuser avec les petits pistons au loïc
y passe toujours dans le champ pour
sponsoriser cette vidéo les gros projets
comme les énormes au casse-tête compris
sur la chaîne et les formes de matière
grise cette vidéo et en partenariat avec
rise of kingdom parce qu'en fait quand
on réfléchit riser kingdom c'est aussi
un casse tête c'est un jeu mobile et sur
table et de stratégie en temps réel
populaire depuis près de trois ans dans
rise of kingdoms est au total 12
civilisation telle que rome la france la
chine
rome est une civilisation auquel
s'attendent commandant qui ont
réellement existé et qui se heurtent les
uns aux autres et la civilisation
vikings arrive bientôt
les avantages de la civilisation vikings
sont l'attaquent d'infanterie la contre
attaque et la charge de troupe décide et
qui remportera la bataille entre les
vikings et la france dirigée charlemagne
et jeanne d'arc contre les vikings la
civilisation française a également des
avantages particuliers sur la santé des
troupes évidemment et la collecte des
ressources
aujourd'hui ces vikings versus france
c'est vous qui décidez de l'histoire
parce que c'est notre rien
après je vous avoue que je jeune d'arc
c'est un peu le feu 1 imaginez vous avez
le pouvoir de construire la civilisation
française de l'époque genre la meilleure
version arrêter d'imaginer et
télécharger rise of kingdom via mon lien
de plus vous avez la chance de
participer à un tirage au sort et de
remporter des prix tels qu'un iphone
blues pro ou min and switch c'est eux
qui gèrent ça vous pouvez télécharger
rise up kingdom bien mon lien ci dessous
pour quoi tu as le mister de d'artagnan
sais tu nous provient ce casse tête
2 alors pas que de internet de la
boutique insoluble mais chez qui je me
procure les cafés exact oui une énorme
boîte que vous voyez apparaître ici
c'était c'était hubert de schengen qui
nous l'avait fabriqué envoyée et ça ça
vient de chez l'insoluble qui se
procurent les casse-têtes les derniers
castex de constantin et de plein
d'autres
c'est un placement de copains l'appui en
train de faire un clair donc je vous
recommande si vous voulez prendre des
casse tête ou des conseils de castets
fait un tour chez vincent lui il ya
toutes les gammes de difficultés tous
les gammes de prix sont très bien ils
sont extrêmement gentils hubert un
coucou à toi cercueil ouvert donc
aujourd'hui
la ebox c'est parti
là ça ça tourne dans les deux sens ça le
bleu il sortait et si j'appuie ça rentre
mais faut forcer un peu ça crackers
d'accord il y en a qui sortent y en a
qui sortent pas ok ça ça tourne
complètement voilà et puis on entend
vraiment un tacle à claques la clac clac
clac clac clac clac clac clac doit y
avoir pas mal de choses qui bloque
ici il n'ya pas de notation particulière
aya temps il ya les encoches aussi au
dessus est bien le même nombre
d'encoches partout oui regarde s'il ya
des petites choses distinctive dans les
traits ou les trucs comme ça un trait
qui serait plus enfoncé que les autres
mais non ça c'est leur accord de
construction
est-ce que ça ça se tourne non bon au
niveau de l'exploration elle est quand
même assez rapide ça s'enlève des fois
dyke hd et mansle à constanta on connaît
maintenant
moi j'essaye de tout tirer je pas fou ok
bon ça avec tes couleurs ça m'étonnerait
qu'ils fouillent le mettre en face mais
il ya peut-être un truc avec les
couleurs complémentaires car celles qui
sont face à face aux autres donc en gros
mettre le jaune ici comme ça je sais pas
pourquoi a clairement je ne sais pas
pourquoi mais je me dis que peut-être ça
a du sens alors tu alors j'arrive à
enlever le bleu j'arrive à le lever et
si je tourne je veux à 6 d'accord je
peux le lever si je le tourne un petit
peu une fois qu'ils en rouge peu plus du
tout le tourner est ce que je peux voir
un peu dans la fente qu'il ya fait
gronder titre bizarre je suis désolé à
d'accord ok on dirait comme un comme une
sorte de bouts de plastique et qui
peut-être si les tournées comme ça
rentre sous ce robot rla effet qu'on
pourrait pas le tourner parce qu'après
on a un tout petit peu de liberté de
mouvement mais pas où et celles qui
étaient sorties aussi
c'était pas le job le bleu foncé aussi
là il sort attend lui sort lui sort lui
n'ont pas bien non oui pourquoi sortir
e on et le 17 mai du coup le plus besoin
en merde c'est pas très joli mais
puisqu'on est de 17 mais ça veut dire
quoi c'est à dire qu'il ya cinq jours
est sorti mon nouveau livre
l'anti guide de la manipulation j'ai
fait une vidéo à ce sujet si vous voulez
voir de quoi ça parle ou comment le lire
sans forcément l'acheter en aussi pour
voir où est ce que vous pouvez
l'emprunter et où vous avez tout ça
c'est un anti guide de la manipulation
la manipulation bienveillante la
malveillante
comment s'en défendre quelles sont les
techniques et au niveau individuel ou
dans les manipulations de masse je vais
vous lire ce qu'elle dit l'auteur selon
rabat il a dit j'ai voulu écrire quelque
chose d'objectif de concret qui vient de
mon expérience de mentalist a sorti
d'études dont je me nourris en
permanence
c'est incroyable je n'aurais pas écrit
mieux bon bref vous avez le lien dans la
description si ça vous intéresse
moi j'en étais là le bleu clair et et
mais qu'est ce que tu fais louis c'est
insupportable c'est de me concentrer en
même temps c'est de la sorte
mais le jeune tout à l'heure et sortait
à 6 ans fait en tournant j'arrive à les
ressortir un peu il y en a que j'arrive
à bloquer vers le haut et d'autres pas
digéré bloqué vers le haut lui aussi lui
pas tant est ce que dans les tournants
tous j'arrive à les sortir c'est ça en
fait la question
mais c'est pas mal mais très stylée en
tout cas avec les couleurs ça change un
peu des castes est un peu terne tout le
temps pour l'instant j'ai pas bien
compris
l'euro ne peut pas de sortir le orange
oui de verre clair un mercenaire rentrée
s'avère fond c'est ça oui oui oui oui
oui oui oui non à s'y abattre mots
pourquoi d'accord là en gros ce que j'ai
fait je les ai tourné jusqu'à temps que
je puisse les libérer
tous ça je l'avais dit je le met en
regard un peu en couleurs opposées ou
complémentaires hélas si j'essaie
d'ouvrir bon ça n'ouvre pas la page
avait pas tellement de doutes dessus
mais je vais juste essayer de tourner ça
au fur et à mesure voir ce que ça donne
qui peut faire une micro accélération
l'altitude
[Musique]
ça n'a rien donné donc ça n'a rien donné
mais pire que ça je sens aucune
résistance sur libération particulière
quand je tourne lui je me demande si
celui-là avec les couleurs et la
correspondance couleur c'est pas juste
une fausse piste et que ce serait pas ça
qui rendrait le casse-tête difficile
c'est possible je le met en face des
bonnes couleurs quand même mais là ils
sont ils sont tous libres et je vois que
j'ai l'impression de rap tout petit peu
plus de jeu que tu as l'air mais je suis
pas sûr je veux pas sur quoi partir
maintenant
parce que comme ils sont libres libres
ils sont libres eux
voilà peut-être ya un truc à faire en
tournant
c'est possible
plus
je sais tourné entièrement en fait celui
du dessous au attendant la sas où vous
beaucoup plus ici là donc il s'est passé
un truc de ce côté là pourquoi je sais
pas est ce que eux ils sont encore
libres n'hésitait pas très bien accès
mais attends messi mais en fait c'est
bon
ou pas
ou pas oui non oui non oui oui oui oui
c'est extrêmement bon alors comment ça a
marché ce truc je transmets il est quand
même temps c'est vrai écoute on est sur
une vidéo pas très longue mais pas moi
ses limites la version son montage
ça c'est rare qu'on les fasse quand même
aussi vite faut que je vérifie les
difficultés mais je crois que c'était un
dur d'accord liant toi que je comprends
pas donc en fait ça
les pistons si on les tourne et ses
terres on est plat et donc il fallait
bien mettre le plat pour que ça passe là
j'imagine les petits trous autour ils
servent à rien et là il ya cette espèce
de flèches de flèches là il fallait
castle ah oui bah oui en fait
ah ouais d'accord ok la flèche quand
l'été face à un des trous j'avais un peu
de jeu mais il fallait vraiment que ce
soit le triangle face au triangle est et
sa face à ça pour que ça marche mais
alors du coup les couleurs tu as les
couleurs c'était vraiment c'était
vraiment juste un attrape idiot c'est
vraiment ça ne servait à rien du tout et
donc le plateau oui c'est pas ça que je
tourne et c'est l ensemble que je
tournais juste sous sa basse et très
stylé ouvrait un que j'aime bien avec un
certain c'est quand même l'originalité
de ces boîtes et les définitions à
chaque fois c'est loin des boîtes
agréable que tu as envie de garder après
que tu as envie de garder mais moi je
peux pas tout garder sinon je vais
ouvrir un musée du casse tête du coup
celui-ci je vous met à gagner sûrement
instagram vous aimons instagram qu'elle
là vous y allé il n'y a pas mille
conditions pour gagner dans des concours
instagram se nomme pas des concours cd
tirage au sort vous laïque et la photo
et vous dites en commentaires que vous
participez et c'est tout y a pas besoin
de me suivre le compte alors ça fait
plaisir mais ce pas obligé il n'y a pas
besoin de tags et d'autres gens ça fait
plaisir n'est-ce pas obligé il n'y a pas
besoin de partager un story ça fait
plaisir mais c'est pas obligé je n'en
peux plus des concours à rallonge je te
connais les concours allonge thorens ta
avons envoyé des tests adn maintenant si
la ebox vous intéresse vous voulez voir
des casse-têtes style est passé voir
chez mes potes de l'insoluble vous mais
leurs liens dans la description c'est
très cool ce qu'ils ont et quoi d'autre
lolo vous pouvez donc télécharger radio
kingdom via mon lien ci-dessous merci
encore à réserve kingdom n'oubliez pas
de tester le jeu en le téléchargeant via
mon
dans la description b-king versus france
c'est vous qui décidez si toi tu veux
c'est leur ouvreur n oubliez pas qu
entre les jambes de lolo est sorti mon
dernier livre vous avez le lien dans la
description pour en savoir plus dessus
tout savoir de quoi ça parle
n'hésitez pas à le lire à l'emprunter
quelque part même à quelqu'un qu'il a
dans une bibliothèque ou médiathèque
pour vous faire un avis dessus je compte
sur vous ici je vous mets la tête de
loïc là vous pouvez vous abonner et
activer la cloche et si je vous mets
deux autres casse tête
on met des gros des petits que du gros
casse-tête à 15000 4444 euros prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt